The joe rogan experience,
how much of a real issue is it when people get fat is mold or just knocks fat?
Fat itself isn't being fat itself.
How much of an effect is being overweight?
It has a big effect,
right?
That's less of a a two actually.
It can be triggered by toxins,
but it's more of a metabolic energy thing.
And that's the other side of what I do.
Uh,
with the supplements that I make,
it's,
it's about increasing mitochondrial function.
And if you have a fueling problem in energy management problem in your body and
being fat as a great sign of that,
you need to figure out why and you need to correct it.
Because when your body works well,
you shouldn't be fat.
Have you noticed this trend where you're not supposed to bring up the fact that
people are fat and it's called fat shaming?
Have we seen this?
I've seen some things on Facebook discussing,
discussing fat or even better celebrating the fact that you're thin is fat
shaming.
Wow.
There was a woman fucking people.
What about thin shaming?
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
It's just people trying to find some sort of an excuse for why they are the way
they are and then the excuse to continue to be the way they are without feeling
any repercussions from socially from other people.
This is a woman,
she had this picture,
she put it on Facebook,
it's her.
She's in a bikini show or like a little,
you know,
one of those little crossfit outfits or something like that,
and she has her three kids there.
Oh,
I saw that picture and the picture says,
what's your excuse?
And people were saying,
you're fat shaming.
A lot of people have different lives,
like whether or not someone has a different life and whether or not someone has
a different issue with their body,
that's not what she's saying.
She's saying,
what's your excuse?
Because this is what she's been able to do.
You're right.
Everybody's different.
Some people have a bad situation that they're in financially.
Some people have bad genetics,
some people they've been taught poorly.
Whatever diseases,
all the above.
But that's not fat shaming.
She's celebrating the fact that she's thin.
You know,
and this,
this fat shaming thing that people love to say now is it completely alleviates
any responsibility you have for your own physical shape.
It's like they want it.
They want to take it out of the equation that that social aspect of being fat,
like there's a reason for it.
The reason for it is it's not healthy for you.
There's the girl.
If you look at that picture up there,
what's your excuse?
Yeah,
but either there's a reason why that exists is because people see what you're
doing and they don't like the way it looks on you because they're scared of it
being on them.
When someone sees a in a morbidly obese person,
the reason why they're staring,
he's not going to try to shame that person.
It's a natural freak out.
Your body recognizes,
oh shit,
that's possible too.
I could do that.
God down.
I better not do that.
I don't want to do that.
That guy looks,
it looks awful.
Oh my God,
that guy's going to die.
That's not fat shaming.
That's a natural thing that people do with a recognize success and failure in
their environment and that success and failure is as much social success and
failure as it is physiological health.
If you see someone that's super unhealthy,
coughing and smoking a cigarette,
that feeling is not cigarette smoking shaming,
okay?
That feeling is you're recognizing that someone is doing something incredibly
unhealthy and that possibility exists for you too.
Here's,
here's the thing,
Joe,
that feeling is not a rational response.
It's a self defense system in the body that happens before you even think about
it.
This is the body going like,
like naturally animals don't want to spend time with other sick animals either.
Like they'll move away from the sick ones and when we see someone,
when our body,
our meat operating systems,
see someone who is sick,
we naturally want to create space.
But here's the thing,
so I weighed 300 pounds.
I was fat for like half of my life and let me tell you,
every fat person on earth knows they're fat.
They do not feel happy about it and they desperately want to fix it,
but they don't want you to rub it in their face.
Dave Asprey,
cause that's fat shaming.
You make me feel bad if you show your six pack,
if you just pull that up like 15 minutes a month,
pitch boom and show that six pack on on Instagram,
you're fat shaming areas that could fucking workout every morning,
an hour and a half a day.
Get yourself in shape,
take a picture and people will be angry because they didn't.
That's amazing.
There will be that.
Sorry.
That's not what the scribe.
Well of course,
but they're saying you're fat shaming.
They're angry because they're trying desperately stuff that doesn't work and
when it doesn't knock often there's some people who just have given up.
I would say most,
I would say most people who are talking about fat shaming or just stuffing
Twinkies down there,
fucking mug.
The people talking about fat shaming have emotional issues,
I would guess,
but you ain't find support online.
That's what I find fascinating.
People agree with them.
The people that called that woman a fat shamer.
There was a lot of them and she,
she had to apologize,
but she was disingenuous in your apology.
And I just,
I,
I feel a lot of compassion for she explain why she just disingenuous.
She did some interview where she was talking about,
you know,
like when she said,
what's your excuse?
Like she can't came up with some sort of a real softening down version of what
she meant by,
what's your excuse,
you know?
But what she meant is she's not fat.
Look,
I'm hot.
What's your excuse?
Here's my kids.
I'm a hot,
it's pretty obvious what she meant.
And she was like,
what's your excuse for not meeting your goals or what?
I kind of get mad though,
when people say your excuses that you're lazy and you're excuses that you didn't
work out enough and you didn't it enough because I beat myself up.
I broke my metabolism,
I broke my thyroid gland working out all the time,
eating a low fat,
low calorie diet and all it did was make me fat and sick and tired.
Like it doesn't work.
So it,
it's,
it's really annoying when you get these people who are genetically gifted have a
good metabolism and never got a chronic illness or whatever the heck works.
So they could basically look good without too much work.
And they stand up there and say,
you know,
you didn't do enough of this.
But when the fat people try and go for a jog,
when you weigh 300 pounds,
he's trying to go for a jog.
It's destructive on your tissues so you can all these fat people who are trying
and just failing miserably and feeling bad about themselves cause they did it
because they got the wrong advice.
Like this is why I started just putting some of this stuff up there.
I don't have to work,
I don't have food cravings,
all that stuff I had struggled with like for a lot of my life.
It just isn't something I have to think about anymore.
And it kind of upsets me when I see,
you know,
fat people who are feeling guilty and like fighting all their willpower on
these,
on these cravings that cause like they're doing it wrong but they don't know
they're doing it wrong so that then they feel guilty and they get caught in all
this emotional stuff and like it's unnecessary.
Yeah.
It seems like there's gotta be a way to get healthy food to people and make it a
part of everyone's everyday diet.
But then you start considering the numbers of people in Los Angeles and if
there's 20 million people,
again,
getting everybody grasp red beef and getting everybody and see tea oil take
over.
Some golf courses are gonna have to put cows on them.
Is that what they're going to have to do?
You can feed an awful lot of cows and some of these grounds,
you're not going to stop people from golfing.
It's too many rich dudes like golfing.
I needs to be a fast food company and it just takes over and just starts doing
it because that's the biggest problem is people just need fast food,
fast food.
Actually healthy.
There's a couple attempts.
There's a guy from,
uh,
one of the early wholefoods guys and some Mcdonald's guys got together and like
they'll make something that's,
uh,
I,
I'm forgetting the name of what they're trying to do,
but they'll make something that's better than it was.
But is it going to be non GMO even?
Is it going to be gluten free now?
Probably not because we have to understand the core tenants of what makes us
healthy and we have to understand those widely before there's demand for them.
Uh,
so,
so the number one predictor for whether you're going to be obese or not is your
income level.
The poorer you are,
the fatter you are.
That's especially true in America and that's a food quality issue.
And it,
it's,
it's just not fair the way things are set up that way.
But if you're poor,
you have a hard time getting food that doesn't make you inflamed.
It doesn't break your insulin.
It doesn't contain things that make you weak in it.
And like it's,
it's tragic.
It shouldn't be that way.
But that's how it is.
There's a blog I read about thin privilege just to sit there.
That's another thing.
That's another way of saying fat shaming.
The other side of saying fat shaming is that being thin you are enjoying thin
privilege and that by creating success and all that,
not just dating success but the way people dress you and the way you move around
in society that you enjoy thin privilege and what they're trying to do is
compare being in shape with being a white male like white male privilege is
white male privilege is almost shameful.
You know,
it's almost shameful to have this white male privilege while people are still,
it's,
it makes you feel,
uh,
like the,
the,
like if someone talks about white male privilege,
what do you think of you think of someone being aloof to the concerns of,
of Brown people and poor people and racism and also allude to the fact that they
got super lucky they got this lucky roll the dice and were born in this way that
allows them to be,
I mean if you think about white males in thinking about white males and you
think about wealth,
majority of the like super wealthy people are white males.
The majority of the people that are in positions of power,
whether it's presidents,
mayor,
white males,
so that white male being a white male and having that privilege,
it's almost like being in a pig.
It's like being the man so thin privilege.
They haven't figured out a way to make being thin,
being a pig
that is so thin,
privileged,
not I'm fat,
not on lazy food.
Like just you know,
re re I didn't re renaming words to mean something different.
Yes,
it's a little bit of that,
but it's also,
it's um,
you pulled up the blog,
right?
Brian did you pull up one of the ones?
It's also alleviating themselves a personal responsibility and finding a new
victim or a new,
a new culprit and the culprit is not their own lack of self respect or their own
willpower or their own ability to discipline themselves or their own ability to
educate themselves on proper nutrition that's out of the equation.
It's no longer their responsibility.
Now instead they'll concentrate on thin people having,
uh,
an acid fits in an actual airplane seat and you know,
being able to squeeze on an actual escalator,
you know,
all of these things,
these fat fucks are complaining about and calling thin privilege.
You've got knock willpower.
That list,
there is no lack of will power and fat people willpower's a finite resource.
You have so much.
You can we prove this beyond a doubt.
What do you mean willpower?
There's a whole book about this now,
and I'm of course for getting the name of the author,
but they actually show that there's so many decisions you can make.
I wrote about this a while back,
there's decision making fatigue and there's x amount of willpower and you can
apply that willpower to change the world.
Or you can apply that willpower to say no to the bullet chips in front of you.
Right?
And if you're a fat person and your energy reserves are low,
and I say this from personal experience,
the amount of willpower it takes to get up off the couch and walk across the
street and do whatever you're going to do,
it requires a hell of a lot more power,
more willpower.
Then you would think it would as a healthy person because your cells aren't
working,
you don't have the energy,
and yet you get up and you do it in every step you take is sapping your
willpower in a way a healthy person doesn't have.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So you're saying that even though willpower is sort of an individual
characteristic and some people having,
some people don't.
With fat people,
it's almost like a catch 22 because the,
although they need it to drop away,
they're not going to have it because they needed to just move around.
Their energy levels are lower so they have less willpower and they're using the
willpower to do simple things that are effortless for you.
And it's not effortless for a fat person.
That is such an interesting point and one that I really didn't consider.
That's a very unique point because I never really considered that fat people
like,
it's almost like they can't help themselves.
It's almost like there's so we'll,
or it's so much more difficult for them to pass on shitty food than it is a
regular person.
Well,
think of it like this.
Okay.
If you're a regular person,
that's thin privilege.
Alright,
so people are real people.
So now it's a trainee thing.
Let's pretend that you're a fat person,
Joe,
and,
and we have a Bagel sitting here.
Okay,
good luck.
Pretend to bitch.
Sorry.
Can't help myself.
So the jokes,
they're the bagels can be talking to you over and over and say,
eat me and it healthy person says,
I don't actually have a craving like fuck you Bagel.
Right?
But if you're a tech guy,
I love bagels.
If you're a fat person,
that Bagel is going to constantly sit and go eat me,
eat me,
eat me.
And every time you say it consciously,
I'm not going to eat the Bagel you are spending your willpower wantonly so every
time you see an ad for Mars on,
on TV now Mars bars or whatever the heck the latest candy is,
and you're like,
God,
I've got to credit.
No.
So you spend your entire day saying no to your biological systems that are
starving for energy.
And this is why you're not deplete it.
You're not lacking willpower.
You're wasting your willpower saying no to foods that are calling out to you and
to biologically unnatural way cause your energy systems are broken,
broken and you have less willpower then you should have had because your cells
aren't functioning right.
Your hormones are broken.
So it never say that fat people are fat.
Because of a lack of willpower.
The fact that they're walking is a testament to their willpower.
What they're lacking is knowledge and they're lacking tools.
And when fat people have those things,
they immediately go and they get thin again.
Okay.
But if that's the case,
then what makes someone go out of their way and get that knowledge?
What makes someone changed their diet?
What makes someone make the difficult steps to start going to a gym?
It's kind of willpower.
Dave Asprey.
There's,
there's definitely willpower component to it,
but things like social support will increase the amount of willpower you have.
Things like encouragement and also things like like dying or being disabled or
finding a diabetic ulcer on your leg and your doctor telling you you're going to
lose your leg if you don't work your ass out.
That can temporarily increase willpower enough that you get your cell cellular
energy kicked off.
Did.
I was reading a thing the other day,
it's just,
I've been railing on about this lately about the idea of people are,
are going on about what they're calling for fat shaming and fat shaming is
making people feel bad for being overweight.
And I've read this one article where this woman was talking about how she was
being fat shamed because she went to a family function and everyone was gushing
about her cousin.
Her cousin lost 20 pounds and the that they were making such a big deal out of
it,
that it was clear to her that they were judging her for not losing the 20
pounds.
So it made her feel awful and she didn't understand how they couldn't understand
that what they were doing was fat shaming her,
complimenting someone on losing weight,
you're fat shaming the person who hasn't lost the weight and that it made her
feel awful and that it was incredibly insensitive of them.
And that,
you know,
I'm fascinated by that kind of thinking.
I really am.
I'm fascinated by that sort of like,
like reverse victimology sort of a thing where instead of you being the victim
of your own handiwork,
you become like a persecuted person because they don't accept you for the flaws
that you have or even mentioned the possibility of those flaws existing by
virtue of complimenting someone for having gotten over the same flaws that you
possess.
Polaris think without even knowing the specifics on us on particular issues
anytime somebody is.
So we linked to embrace the victim role.
Uh,
his mouth traveled right away.
I'm like,
do you know there's a reality to losing weight that we have this Dave Asprey guy
who's an expert in a lot of aspects of nutrition.
He's a fascinating guy and one of the things he was talking about where is he
was giving a overweight people a pass because you're saying the level of
addiction that these people actually have for food to say that they don't have
willpower is really unfair because there are so overweight.
Like a lot of these folks are so far gone that they used up all of their
willpower just to get up in the morning just to walk to the bus stop,
just to go,
go to work,
just to get their,
their,
their chores done during the day.
Like they don't have the same level of energy that a healthy person has.
So to tribute them to having like this,
there's this like backlog of energy than not tapping into because they're weak
willed.
It's not that like they're,
they're already so far in the hole,
it's almost impossible for them to get motivation.
They have to get something like incredibly extreme has to happen to them.
And I thought that was really unique and and looking at it that way I people to,
yes,
yes.
People out of shape.
People who are depressed,
you could see the in with people that are ruining their life too,
whether it's through addictions,
you know,
you see that as well.
It's like why can't they see it the way other people see it?
It's almost like they can't,
like they're so trapped up in the momentum of whatever it is.
Whether it's gambling or food.
I mean,
I've seen people with food addictions that you can watch the gears spinning in
their mind when food is near my,
like they know they're supposed to lose weight and they know they're not
supposed to be eating it,
but the the gears start spinning in their mind and that becomes the primary
focus of their existence.
Get that fucking doughnut.
I need that donut.
That donut is huge.
It's,
it's,
it's critical for fueling whenever whatever it trouble is going on in their mind
and it's a weird aspect of human beings and you don't do that any favors by
pretending that encouraging someone who lost weight is a bad thing.
The idea that socially that's irresponsible because you're fat and you're near
them.
No,
it's actually responsible because that terrible feeling that you have,
it's supposed to be the bump that pushes you towards eating a salad instead of a
cheeseburger should be the bump that makes you write down everything you eat
that day and state some goals.
This is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to use my willpower to overcome this horrible obsession that I have.
Was shitty food.
That's also possible.
It's also possible by,
by you going home and blaming everybody in the blog that you've projected
yourself away from any potential benefit from having these bad feelings.
Again,
he's the same as the amount.
The competition is somebody who never learned how to lose,
and the same in a avoiding criticism like you gotta you gotta look it.
It's a,
it feels like shit,
but that feel like shit.
Correct it so it doesn't feel like shit anymore.